do you know why they tell you to save
money
i don't know
because the system of banking york has
nothing to do with communism or
capitalism
it's the banks run the world
the rich run the world
they don't carry your communism
capitalist
so when you save so let's say you say
one dollar you as a one euro one yen
the banking system can lend out 10.
so the entire system is called the
fractional reserve system
the fractional reserve system is also
printing money
then they tell you to save money so they
they want you to save money so they can
lend out your money 10 times
so your dollar became worthless 10 times
over
and then
they used to pay you 10 interest on your
money now it's at best one percent
and they're still lending it out ten
times
so that's why you don't save money is
because your money is becoming worth
less and less and less and less and less
the banks are getting richer and richer
and richer
then they tax you on that interest you
they pay you that one percent interest
if they pay you that much japan is zero
and the japanese are so stupid they
still save money
we also have zero yeah and they still
save money how stupid is that
so that's what i question so how come
that happens
now if i borrow money guess what do i
pay taxes on debt
i guess no
why's that
i know this is this is what i'm saying
okay question everything okay so when
they lend out money
that's how money is created money is
debt they lend out them why is debt tax
free
i don't know
because that's how money is created
and so the banks love it they love
people borrow lots of money
so how do i get rich i borrow money
and i buy assets with it
the poor person borrows money and buys
liabilities like purses
cars houses and they get poorer and
poorer and poorer
but i use
debt i borrowed 300 million after the
crash dollars
in 2000 by 2010 i had borrowed 300
million dollars to buy real estate that
made me rich and the interest rates kept
coming down so that my cost of money
kept coming down
and so everybody else is saying oh you
should get out of debt you know why
because they don't question the hypnosis
they're under you've been hypnotized to
work hard for money
to save it
the fractional reserve system prints it
and then
you pay taxes of taxes so i get i have
all this debt
and i get rich rule number one and rich
dad poor doesn't rich don't work for
money
most people miss that one but that goes
back to 1971 when nixon took us out the
gold standard yeah and money became fake
money yeah so anyway um
my rich i was preparing me to think
about how can i make money without
making money without money
and the way i do it i create an asset
like a book
i'm not saying write books because
that's a tough industry
but i write a book today
i sell 50 licenses
to 50 different languages and i ca i
collect royalties for years the long
tail
yeah so my money just keeps coming in
from with that i i borrow so let's say i
make 10 in a book
i'll borrow fifty dollars to invest in
real estate
i step up my basis for depreciation
advertising and uh appreciation good job
that's financial education yeah yeah
that garbage they teach you about in the
festival and long-term in the stock
market why would i do that
when i can make up my own assets yeah
you know that's what entrepreneurs do
every entrepreneur should be making up
their own assets and staying out of the
stock market that's my point of view but
can everybody do it no of course not
sure but i've screwed up enough times to
prove i can do it
and my accountant will back me up yeah
the guy is an idiot but he does create
assets the tax department which every
country has taxes
determined they want to know what kind
of income do you work for so when you
say to someone your age or a child to
the parent parent to the child
they say is go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
earned income
as you can see from this diagram here
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here
and the first thing you pay is the
highest taxes
because you worked for money
yeah the government doesn't want you
working for money
they punish you for that they want you
to hire employees
or invest
okay so earned income is what they work
for the second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if i buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand i sell it
for two hundred thousand hundred
thousand is capital gains if i buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest text
so the tax breaks that president trump
is working on today is primarily for
these guys here
so there are doctors lawyers
highly educated people and they have
stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff of
flipping houses you get a break
but what the really rich work for is
passive income
and passive income
[Applause]
for me
i have a business
whether i work or not money comes in
and you've seen me i'm not here am i no
never never
i've earned the right not to be here
real estate i get milli half mil every
year my wife and i came we had more real
estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still got this
but this is another type of
income
this here i'll
get into is called phantom income
it's taxes i don't pay so it's a little
bit beyond most people's minds
but let's say my tax bill is a hundred
thousand dollars by doing what the
government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break
that means fifty thousand in taxes i
don't have to pay
[Music]
so the fifty thousand dollars it didn't
go to the government they went back up
here
so that's what financial education does
is it teaches you
about the financial statement which is
not taught in school again they teach
you fico scores which is really fido
scores
it was your total dougie
okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching you to work for now
ironically
when you save money and you have a 401k
this is the kind of income so savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better is the saving money in
what he called it 401ks is good
in canada it's called rrsp in australia
called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because
i'm an active investor i don't buy this
because this is passive investors
i am active and i'm professional in all
of these areas
so i work for passive income which means
i'm not here
the check comes in the checks come in
every year and you've seen kim and i
and your mother now
she's working on here
and so your mother's income keeps going
up your father's income keeps going up
and they don't have a job there's three
kinds of income
this ordinary portfolio passive
so when you say to some poor kid go to
school get a job
they're working for ordinary income the
highest tax income in the world
i don't work ordinary income i don't
want a paycheck
passive income is generally what happens
when you invest in the stock market
i mean portfolio income
so they say well i bought tesla at 100
it went up to 200 i sold it so i made
100
that's portfolio
that's taxed at the next higher level
so when i have passive income
it's tax free
getting passive income you have to know
what you're doing so that's why the best
first of all bookkeeper accounts
attorneys bankers
i operate as a team just like my when we
flew into combat we're a team
and most people are trying to do it
self-employed way
you know i'm a good computer programmer
good
you pay the highest taxes you work the
hardest you don't get ahead that way
but that's what most people they want to
do it on their own you know if you want
it done right
do it by yourself
an employee is always saying the same
words you know this year and this year
i'm looking for a safe secure job
with uh benefits and a paycheck and uh
pension that you got that
that's what they're looking for
so if i have a job well
and a self-employed person said how are
you doing i'm the best
good i'll hire the best
but you the government's gonna penalize
you for that because you're because
you're working for a quiet blended
income but it's more passive things it's
actually ordinary income but um
pay the highest taxes the tax law are
nothing but incentives not punishments
so if you donate if i i just donated uh
money to the food bank because they're
out of a lot of food as well as ten
thousand bucks
i get a tax credit
i don't donate money to the food bank no
tax break
so because i have seven 000 rental
apartment houses
i got a tax break you know why because
i'm providing housing
and because i have thousands of
employees
the tax break the government even sent
me money to pay my employees what do you
recommend people do in a market that is
potentially heading into depression
should they be saving cash
and thinking about
you know
becoming more liquid like what are some
of the things that they should do well
it depends upon the cash
if uh if you're in argentine is it right
peso
yeah
i wouldn't touch it
i'd say of gold and silver
see what's what's his name uh what's his
head edgewater's hedgeway no bridgewater
scholars
yeah he says it depends upon the
currency you're in sure he says
so like zimbabwe their debt is financed
with external money
japan is internally financed
so that's why the depression doesn't
hurt them as badly so you have to learn
so much about that
so i own millions and millions and
millions and millions of millions in
gold because i started buying gold in
1973 when it was illegal for americans
owned gold
and i like gold and silver because
there's no counterparty at risk there's
no other party to it gold and silver are
god's money
so people say well it's not a good
investment i said
yeah but
i sleep at night what's that worth
yeah sure so i don't care if the dollar
the dollar is corrupt the us dollar is
corrupt but
it's the strongest currency in a
horrible currency world yeah so if
you're u.s save dollars you're in
argentina don't save save gold right
save bitcoin do you think bitcoin would
be i mean i mean bitcoin is going to has
problems too but you're saying i would
so when you say save money you got to
say what what currency yeah what
currency over my lifetime i've raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
and it's because i don't have i didn't
have money as a young person
that i learned how to raise capital
and and it's really quite simple you
have to find an asset
that's worth more than me you know if
they can't invest in me because that's
called slavery you know
they're going to buy me you know so what
i do is you know i started off i write
about it in fake
i started off looking for this one
little piece of real estate
i found an excuse you know this
one bedroom one bath condominium on the
beach in maui
and i found an excuse for people to give
me the money
all i had to do is assure them i'd pay
them back
so my first deal was an infinite return
deal
i had no money in the deal because it
was 100 percent debt it was an 18 000
condo you can't touch them for that much
anymore but the economy was bad
so i buy this eighteen thousand dollar
condo the guy wanted ten percent down
you know you don't need higher math
ten percent of eighteen thousand is how
much sports fans
eighteen hundred dollars
i could have used my money i had the
money
but that would be too easy i understand
something i don't have stock spots
mutual funds you know why
why i could make up my own assets
i wrote this book called rich dad poured
at 31 million copies to make five
dollars a book you do the math on that
one
i create my cash flow game i think i
make six
six or seven dollars a game sure in 50
languages
i know how to sell i said to young
people the millennials you know you've
been screwed
you know you're being left for the world
that's absolutely horrible shape
financial and all this
student loan debt pensions are
collapsing financial systems are
collapsing the rich are getting richer
but apparently somebody gave you
something to get yourself out of this
and what the millennials have that i
didn't have was the iphone
the iphone is the single most powerful
i cannot believe how much power that
thing has
so it seems to me i'm not really
religious i'm not not political
but i'm saying that
god does provide at some level and god
provided the millennials with an iphone
holy mackerel all you have to do is sync
your brain to that iphone
you have more power than you and i ever
had when we're their age you know you
know what i mean the trouble is if they
don't haven't gone to school and they
have a teacher
that is incompetent and we've all had
income competent teachers
their brain and the iphone are not
synced into making money
dude i mean there and
if you can't make money with your iphone
there's something wrong in your brain
not the iphone screen most people
haven't seen
this here is real silver
plata
okay that's what it looks like and so in
1972
and this here is gold yeah
this is god's money this is what god's
money looks like
the reason i call it god's money is you
can't fake it
you know you can fake it with a fake etf
like a gold etf or a silver which i
don't touch because it smells as bad as
the guys that printed that crap
you know i mean
jesus but this is real money so
you look at this here
when i first started buying that that
was a dollar forty yeah
today that's sixteen dollars
and this here is auto gold
and the reason we brought it is most
people haven't seen or touched this is
real this is god's money why did i say
it's god's money because it was here
when the earth was created yeah and
it'll be here when we're all dead and
gone when you're saving those fake
dollars
this will still be here yeah or those
fake etfs or those fake stocks
so this here is called the green box
these are there's 500 of these little
tubes like this wow
500
coins in here
and this is one which is worth more
which one's with more
the gold yeah this is worth more than
all that
now the reason i say this is because for
your generation
this could be the biggest opportunity
you'll ever see i'm not making any
commissions on this stuff yeah of course
but
if you look at what happened with the
fake central bank see the purpose of the
central bank or the fed or all you know
the
japanese
the bank of japan or the european
central bank they pump out fake money
the purpose of central banks like the
fed is to protect the banks not you
they're a criminal operation as far as
i'm concerned
you're going to find that most of my
talks about the fed
so i would recommend you guys buy this
stuff
don't save money
don't save government money because
they're corrupt as hell as you
know save god's money now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you the
property
was a little condominium
one bedroom
one bath
eighteen thousand dollars
u.s
it was on the beach of maui
the reason the price was so low is the
market had crashed
smart investors always wait for the
crash
so this thing crashed
i had to look at 100 properties once i
left the class three-day class i had to
look at 100 properties in 90 days
and write a one-page report on each of
those properties
as my instructor said to me when i left
that three-day class i was 26 years old
and the instructor says your education
begins
when you leave the class
as your education will begin
when you leave this class
not now
so you have a chance to talk to carlos
you have a chance to talk to alvaro
talk to them find out learn doesn't cost
you any money
change your ideas
so with this here the instructor said
i had to borrow
buy the investment for zero
money
okay
zero money
most people will tell you
i can't invest because i don't have
money
that's a loser
please understand this
this was
1974.
the dollar had just gone off the gold
standard everything was coming up fast
so
i had to figure out how to buy it for
zero
and the reason i say that is most poor
people like padre pobre always says i
can't afford it
i know some of you right now saying well
i can't afford it i don't have time i
have children i have a job i have bills
to pay
and it is those excuses that keep you
poor
if you do not change that talk in your
head you will always be the poor person
i just think about the economy business
okay world affairs i i want to my job is
to make
complex financial systems simple enough
so the average person can understand it
that is extremely difficult
because most people are brainwashed when
it comes to money
go to school
get a job
work hard
pay your taxes
save money get out of debt buy a house
and invest in a stock market
everybody who follows that program has
been brainwashed i don't even care about
money i make a lot of money because i
understand the system
i would never go to school get a job
work hard save money get out of debt buy
a house and invest in a stock market i
do everything exactly opposite you wake
up tomorrow morning let's have some fun
with us
you wake up tomorrow morning
and you're on the street
and you have nothing
you don't have a single
contact
in your network
all you have is the knowledge
and experience that you've had
throughout your career how do you build
up from there
well i've been there many times
so it's no big deal you just figure out
what's needed and wanted and you go do
it
you know
people always
kind of dump on
what you call the fast food industry
if i had to do it again i could work for
mcdonald's
and the reason i go work for mcdonald's
you know whether it's seven bucks an
hour or 15. i don't really care
i don't really like mcdonald's food but
they have the best business systems in
the world
you know how else can a company
take virtually non-college educated
people and build a fast food industry
across the world and they have the best
system so right inside little mcdonald's
you can learn everything you need to
learn about business except for the
management side of it
so i just go work at mcdonald's so i can
learn even more so i look at
life as learning i'm constantly learning
you know i'm reading constantly studying
constantly
i spend my most of my time with
entrepreneurs
i don't spend my time with people who
complain about the economy you know
so nothing will really change
i just go back to being an entrepreneur
you know if you want to stay small be
the smartest guy on the block and that's
why most accountants most attorneys most
doctors never get rich is because
they're too narrow you know they're
experts in toenail removal or something
you know what i mean or my attorney a
poor guy is an a student he knows jack
about outside of that
whereas i never had i'm not
i flaunt that high school twice because
i can't write it's iron if i'm right
here today
but the reason i'm pretty good is
because in the military we're taught to
be generalists not specialists
so when i sit down with my team i have
accountants i have attorneys i have
media guys i have it guys i have graphic
designers and all this so i operate as a
team
since i don't know anything so in
actuality being a great entrepreneur
means i could be the laziest guy and i
can know the least
but i have to have a very smart team
with just a ring finger around me
so because i was never smart i had
respect for people who are smart and a
lot of times i meet a students and they
think they're the smartest guys on
planet earth and that lack of respect
will keep them small and that's what
most corporate guys want to do stay
small you know you're going to climb
that corporate ladder you've got to beat
the other guys with a job and it's all
that stuff it's not the way an
entrepreneur really works it's it's
corporate it's school system you know
you got to beat up for the grades you
got the best grades i don't have to be
the best but i have to hang out with the
best well
the thing is you see when people
economies go up economies go down we
might go into a depression worldwide
like i said
france is in very big trouble germany is
okay england's in big trouble
china's in trouble
so if we go that we go to a worldwide
depression and it might take ten years
you know to come out of it
but during these times
this is the best time i have made more
money in the last three years than ever
before in my life
you know i i bought five i bought five
golf courses last year
out of banks that's impressive yeah
well the banks
yeah donald bought 10.
they're giving them away
no one told me
yeah but you have to know how to operate
them you know you have to be an
entrepreneur yeah so the banks just call
you up and they say that there was this
one there was five golf courses and one
hotel in the states in arizona yeah gulf
mecca you know
and this japanese company had it and
they asked me if i wanted to buy it
about five years ago for 260 million i
said does it make sense you know it
doesn't make sense at 260 million
so they told me i didn't know what i was
doing they said okay bye
and then last this one year ago this
summer the citibank called up and says
you want those golf courses
and they gave me the money to buy them
one of the things i i stress here at
rich dab which i never i didn't do for
much of the time was because
once kim and i had enough money the
question is what do you do next
and if kim and i had continued to work
for money i think i would have died so
when kim retired she was 37 and i was 47
but just as we said on this
with vonte it's one of your primary
objectives especially today
is when do you plan to retire
because you know the idea of having a
job and waiting for your 401k or your
stock market to save you
i think you're going to be sadly
disappointed because
what i'm forcing is a massive crash
coming it's going to wipe out a lot of
people
and i'm coming up with a new book called
who stole my pension and all these guys
who think their pension is safe
i think wall street has other ideas on
their pension here
so when i say to young people like you
guys i said you know plan your
retirement the day you start working
you know when do you escape from the rat
race that's the cash flow game there i
only became an entrepreneur because it
was the greatest challenge i could take
on as far as my personal education
personal development yeah
and it wasn't to make money you know and
as i said my first business was a nylon
and velcro surfer wallet business and
the mistake i made i was successful
and we grew internationally so fast
i just couldn't finance my success
and so i started borrowing money and
which was good i started to learn how to
raise capital i learned i learned how to
negotiating you know in the reason i was
in korea fighting taekwondo was i was
out there negotiating anyway for
production because we were manufacturing
in
hawaii where the cost of manufacturing
was too too high
so i had to fly to korea and taiwan to
negotiate manufacturing
i tell you man you're not stupid until
you're negotiating against koreans and
taiwanese man those guys had me coming
and going up one side and down the other
but that's what i did it for
you know what i mean is to learn and to
learn to finance learn how to factor you
know how to
how to ship and then factor my inventory
and all this stuff i learned so much
as i was going broke successfully going
broke and so when i explained to young
people that's what i did it for that so
that's how you get smarter
but in this academic culture you know
we're just talking about jordan peterson
how he yeah he rails up against
academics on the academic culture the
person who makes the most mistakes is a
stupid person
but an entrepreneur the person that
makes the most mistakes and learns from
them is the smart sp is the rich person
so i always say to young entrepreneurs
it's not money will never make you rich
you know it's your experience your how
much you learn the mistakes you make the
people you make
and all those horrible experiences are
all good experiences if you learn from
them sure and that's the attitudinal
difference of an entrepreneur most guys
are small business guys they're not
entrepreneurs
you know they open a pizza shop to make
money and they get stuck in that pizza
shop forever you know like well that's
not me
and the subject of entrepreneur
is a massive subject so you got a drug
dealer
peddling drugs is also an entrepreneur
as is jeff bezos running the biggest
product pushing country in the company
in the whole world they're both
entrepreneurs but the gap between the
drug dealer and bezos massive
so when i speak to young people so what
kind of entrepreneur do you want to be
and if you're just here to make money
since you can do that but it's not
exciting entrepreneurs have one thing in
common
they keep going they'll change the rules
they'll reinvent them
you know they don't just take one answer
so a real entrepreneur really makes no
difference which country you're in
that's my beliefs i'm not i i love that
you know i mean it's just a mindset
you know
if you
you mess with me i'll find a way around
it
you know i have a friend
he's a
multi-multi-multi-family rich guy from
france and you know france is as
communistic as it gets
75 top line for million dollar earners
yeah but that's why he lives here yeah
so
[Music]
he he started buying vineyards in napa
and sonoma
so he went back to the french government
and says it's his wine
he says i want to ship my wine in bulk
to california
and the government says you can't do
that
this is the french government's and you
can't share it and here's a guy who's i
think he's five generations
you know french blind guy this guy is
this guy is an entrepreneur entrepreneur
he says okay i can't ship it in barrels
a guy goes yeah he says okay i'll jump
in bottles
so he battled all of his stuff it cost
him more money
but he still figured out how to do
creativity
now he has
his wine with his california wine and
all this
and so he went back to the french
conference here try this see if it's not
better
and so now they're all confused because
he didn't break any rules
so i'll say it again
entrepreneur has a mindset first
a skill set
and rules
and depending upon whether you're
employee or small business the rules are
different
the mindsets are different the skill
sets are different what's your
philosophy when it comes to human
resources how do you get the right
people and then how do you keep the
right people it's the most important
part of business
you know that's why i went to military
school
then i went to i was a marine corps
the reason why i talked to military
veterans you probably have the most
important skill of all
because all we're trained to do whether
you're at a general
or private you're taught to be leaders
it is a number one skill of an
entrepreneur is people skills and
leadership skills
and unfortunately most people don't have
it coming into so when i do my talks to
veterans and all this stuff i really
want to encourage them you know because
they're pretty depressed because they
can't get you know they're a walmart
reader which is a good job
but they're afraid to take the leap into
entrepreneurship
so but military guys i don't care what
branch of service just by the
indoctrination process and the survival
rate whether you go to combat or not
is that you learn leadership skills
people skills you've got to have that
you know whether whether you're a team
of one
you still have to deal your customers
and the good customers bad customers
lawsuits
uh taxes
government regulations and all this
they're all people skills
you know so when somebody says to me
what do i need to learn i said boy you
better learn how to communicate pretty
quickly to people you don't like
and get them on your side you know how
to win friends and influence people
basic book the number one skill of an
entrepreneur is people skills well most
successful entrepreneurs have gone bust
right you know henry ford an old time
entrepreneur he went bust five times
okay look you look at steve jobs yeah
his own board fired him yeah you know
bill gates was taken before the supreme
court for monopolistic practices right
even my friend donald trump went down a
billion dollars yeah i only went down a
million so the average person is so
afraid of those losses
they never get ahead
because at school they teach you if you
make a mistake
or if you fail you're a failure but
that's not real life
a baby learns to walk by
standing up and falling down standing up
and falling down
and our school system punishes you for
making mistakes
that's why my poor dad and academic
was so unsuccessful he was terrified of
making mistakes well as we know there's
fewer and fewer jobs you know american
corporations say they're hiring but
they're not hiring in america they're
hiring overseas
but more than that is that the reason i
endorse network marketing is most people
are addicted to the paycheck
and the paycheck is one of the most
sinister plots ever pulled upon a human
being
if you need a paycheck you've sold your
soul
you know you sold your body your mind
your spirit and your emotions you sit
there in fear of losing your job or can
i get a raise or you know will i get
promoted
i mean and then and then why would you
do that and the other thing about reason
we endorse network marketing we don't
think of it as a network marketing we
think of it as entrepreneur development
because if you need a paycheck this is
not your business
you know we build businesses
so sometimes when kim and i do a deal we
may not receive a paycheck for five six
years
you know and so these guys come
am i gonna get rich quick
you know and some people do i don't know
you do or not but that is an employee
get rich loser mindset and so the thing
that network marketing does is really
kind of cure you of that loser paycheck
get rich quick mentality and actually
build a business
you know we build businesses
but and that's how we're rich but we
didn't get rich quick and i don't need a
paycheck and i never want a paycheck so
that's kind of a revolutionary thought
to most people up there who went to
school
to get good grades and get a job you
know they get a high paying job and then
the higher paying job you pay higher
taxes and you wonder why you never get
ahead that's because you went to school
to get a job and a paycheck you've got
to get away from the paycheck and
sometimes it might take two three years
to get away from that and that's what
network marketing teaches people it's an
entrepreneur's mindset it's an
entrepreneur's spirit not a loser
employee i need a paycheck mentality i'm
trying to explain to you when they tell
you get out of debt
that's
because the money is debt
and the only way money gets out of debt
is via taxes so all the people who work
for money red rich dad poor dad what's
lesson number one
rich people don't work for money correct
money is debt
i use debt as money
and everybody thinks getting in debt is
bad well who told you that
i think the stock market is for losers
why would you put money in the stock
market when it's manipulated
that's what i think about so i'm always
watching the manipulation going on
behind the scenes
that's what my brain is focusing on all
the time and i don't pay taxes the
question is how is it i don't pay taxes
i can tell you
that's not that's an important question
because most people are so most
romanians and most people in the united
states cheat on their taxes because they
hate taxes so much
but you don't have to cheat on taxes if
you understood how money was working
you think donald trump pays taxes
no
nobody has seen his tax returns yeah i
know him he's my friend
we don't pay taxes
that's the question how is it we do that
that's an intelligent question
the reason you can't ask me this
question because you don't know how i do
it that's what i'm thinking about i'm
constantly thinking about how do i make
money how do i serve more people how do
i create new businesses
make more money and pay less taxes and
serve more people i am very shy
very very shy
you know i came back from vietnam
and i could kill people but i couldn't
talk to people
[Music]
and one day i said to my when i decided
to follow my rich dad's footsteps i just
said to him
i want to be an entrepreneur he says you
got one problem i said what's that
you're shy
i said what's wrong with being shy he
says you gotta sell
you got to handle rejection
number one skill can you handle
rejection
the answer is no i couldn't handle it
so i said i still don't want to learn
how to sell
so that this was in 1973 i was 25 years
old
and my rich dad said how's your love
life
he said it sucks
is he getting laid i said no
he says because you can't sell
guys got it
so when i talk about what skill do you
need
when the hits the fan you better start
selling so i went to work for xerox in
1974 so i can learn how to sell
it took me four years
and i was number one
okay and today i'm a best selling author
you know most phds tell me i can't write
yes i said i can't write but i can't
sell
if you can't sell you don't make money
period
end the statement
you know just because you have a product
doesn't mean jack
but the important thing is you start
i don't care what product you start with
but you start
and i started off with nylon wallets
success wiped me
out you know we couldn't sell couldn't
sell also it took off then i couldn't
finance i couldn't finance couldn't find
the ass because the sales kept going
through the roof
now
trouble is i kept borrowing and i
couldn't sustain the sales
next lesson
but that's how we learn
okay you know i don't know if you saw me
on uh
patrick ben david you know that guy's a
guy is a genius member i love working
with him he's smart yeah yeah oh she's
smart he's kind of i used to work with
tony robbins and he has that quickness
of brain yeah
i'm a little hawaiian a little slower
but anyway he goes
he goes uh i told him you know during
the
agrarian age the church was the center
so every small town had a church
so it was very spiritual and that was
the culture
we shifted the industrial age and then
weaponry came up so we could now kill
you know that we went from swords to
guns to machine guns to rockets to
drones you know
so during the industrial age they
started building statues to war heroes
so that was a you know as a marine they
had the marines raising the flag on
iwajima and they have robert e lee and
grant and
so everybody everybody respected war
heroes and
stuff like that
now
they're tearing down robert e lee and
grant and all these guys
because america is now worshiping the
victim
figure brutality the victim mentality
and that's what i said on patrick about
david
and a couple of my friends called me and
said here
and i said well you're entitled to your
opinion but i've been called better you
know and stuff like this but i said
we're raising victims
our schools are pumping out victims and
the reason i like this guy jordan uh
peterson
is he says it's not what a person stands
for you see that he did this great thing
it's what are they against
he says a lot of times i'll stand up
there say well i stand for socialism but
they're really against the rich
and so that's why i wouldn't talk about
andrew yang and
uh
pete buttajedge and all this stuff i
wonder what they really stand for
what are they really fighting for
so i'm upfront with you i'm fighting for
capitalism yeah you know i fight for
education
that we should have a better education
i'm not saying anything else inside that
i don't have a hidden agenda sure sure
so when these guys are talking about
we're going to fix the homeless i said
and what does that mean and so what uh
jordan peterson says this is they're
against the rich
they're not for the homeless they're
against the rich
and that's where most of the people in
the left are i don't know that because
i'm not political not republican or
democrat you don't have any religious
agenda you don't believe in god fine the
lord believing god fine but
it's i want to know what you really
stand for
not what you pretend to be standing for
you see there's three types of ways
people work number one is a job
number two is a career and number three
is a calling
so let's look at it this way
it's not the job you do
it's your point of view on it so a
school teacher i would say probably 30
40 it's just a job
you know they're school teachers not
because they like teaching but they like
the benefits they like to pay
you know for them the paycheck is the
reward for doing something they don't
want to do
the second is a career so a school
teacher goes in that this is my career
you know someday i'll be vice principal
or you know some superintendent and
things like that so that's their career
and then we've all had teachers where
their whole life soul
is in teaching those are the best
teachers
well those are the ones i remember i
also remember the ones who were the job
guys they were the worst some of the
worst i've ever had
you know i just argued and fought with
them
they are the reason i left school
so when i talk to entrepreneurs i say is
it just a job
is it your career to be an entrepreneur
or is it your calling
and there's nothing right or wrong just
be honest with yourself you know right
now i'm going to start a taco shop
because i need to make some money
knock yourself out you know
but when i started my first business it
was not to make money necessarily money
is important because money is fuel for
the business
but i wanted to learn to be an
entrepreneur so i started nylon velcro
wallets
i don't love the product product sucks
but i wanted to be a great entrepreneur
so i was willing to do a product
that i wasn't passionate about
but i was passionate about learning to
be an entrepreneur and then when i
became successful as an entrepreneur
i have enough money i said what do i
want to do next and i retired at 47. i
had enough money coming in
and i said well
i hated school
i loved education i just hated school
i loved most of my teachers i just hated
school you know because every time they
said to me go to school and get a job i
said but i don't want a job i want a
business
you have to get a job
did i mean it was the programming i
didn't like
so with that said
i became an entrepreneur in education
and today i make millions as a teacher
but i make it as an entrepreneur so when
people say well don't you have enough
money i said it's not about the money
at this point because i have plenty
it's about the job you know it's what's
my calling what's what bucky fuller said
you must trust your intuition
you know and it's called your gut
feeling a lot of times and scientists
have just recently found out there's
actually brain material in your gut
that's why you get a bad feeling
and that's kind of where intuition comes
from it's more from your gut rather than
your brain
and my intuition kind of changed because
i went to vietnam twice i was a good
marine marine u.s marine pilot and all
this i was doing it for god country in
america you know all this stuff
and one day i was standing on the
battlefield in 1972 and i said
what am i doing here you know why am i
killing these people i don't hate them
they don't hate me
and that's when my life you know you
start start waking up as you grow older
so i learned to trust my intuition
and say what i had to say like this book
is about the future also follows a
futurist
so for me to write rich dad poor dad in
1997 nearly 20 years ago was about the
future it wasn't about 1997. the
question i ask you is are you following
the herd
you know the herd generally goes off the
cliff like a bunch of lemmings
and how many are doing what your mommy
and daddy told you what to do
go to school get a job
invest in a well-diversified portfolio
stocks bonds mutual funds and etfs
is that what you're doing
are you hoping that the next person
elected whether it's president trump or
one of the other candidates will save
the economy
well we have a very important show for
people like you
because this program is about you have
to do the exact opposite
of what everybody else is doing because
if you keep doing what everybody's doing
i'm afraid everybody's going to go off
the cliff
that cliff is not too far away right now
well you know that's why i keep saying
to the younger the millennials you know
if they're a pack of wimps
you know i meet millennials who are just
horrifyingly weak
snowflakes i call them you know
they go to college at formats
they're taught
trigger events or whatever you know
i don't know what they say today but
they've got to have special rooms where
there's no
whatever i'm going holy mackerel
welcome to the real world you know and
there's other millennials who are as
tough as nails i mean this is the
biggest opportunity they've ever had
huge
so it just depends upon what's between
this year and this year what's in your
heart the big question is how much is
enough
you know because i think the reason kim
and i are successful as we always
started small
we actually stay small kitchen table and
we we do keep doing the same thing but
we don't ever
try to get big we got big
but i think we caught big by staying
small we did i mean our core group is
very small yeah and then we license out
so for those of you who think you have
to start some mega company or be you
know make millions of dollars that's not
really true a big part of what makes a
company successful is whether or not
they have a brand b-r-a-n-d almost
misspelled it okay
and brand people think well it's the
communication you know but a brand is
more than that the reason rich dad is so
valuable right now is because it is an
internationally known brand the same way
as trump is known as a brand
and the real question on a brand is not
just communication so a brand makes it
easier to sell when somebody says rich
dad they all i think i heard of that or
i know what the guy stands for and all
this so what a brand really is is the
entire bi triangle if you're going to
create a brand especially in a world
that's overcrowded with com advertising
communication the webs ipods print
blogs i mean there's so much competition
now for a person's time
it really is more important that you
become a brand so there's a shortcut
communication like if i say the word
ferrari you know you get a picture of
something in your mind it's a whole body
effect but if i said hyundi or kia
you know car they're probably just as
good a car but you get a whole different
emotional effect just by the brand name
so i'm not saying hyundai's are better
or worse than a ferrari but i'll pay
more for ferrari than i will for a
hyundai i don't own a hyundai by the way
i own a ferrari what does it mean it's a
shortcut communication
like if i say the word apple you know
some people think of compute computers
and some people think of red apple
but for the guys like me who i'm an
apple fanatic you know the brand means a
lot to me i love steve jobs he's one of
the best entrepreneurs in the world
right now
and if i say the word marine corps
marine corps is a brand it communicates
everything the mission the team the
leadership the style the message and the
marines have a saying we're only looking
for a few good men and women
that means we just don't want to be like
the army we have to position ourselves
away from the arm of the air force and
the coast guard and the navy
so brands are so vitally important as a
communication tool especially in today's
over communicated two world there are
more people competing for your customers
mind their time you know how many blogs
can you read how many magazines can you
read how many television sets can read
how many
games can you play in all this so today
if you're going to be an entrepreneur it
becomes more and more important that you
become a brand i always say quit your
job but that's not you know i don't have
a job i never i've only had one job
and i never wanted a job after that
because i had to be hungry
not to say you know but
we're all different we're humans we're
different beings if i share this diagram
here you know
it's why i created my cash flow board
game
because we have four different
intelligences we have mental
intelligence we have i don't know what
that one is
spastology
you probably have very good physical to
make you know football and all that yeah
emotional intelligence but spiritual
intelligence
so i went to military school in new york
the first thing is spiritual
you know i become a marine that's
spiritual yeah you know what i mean
because you're putting your life on the
freaking line yeah you know so nazim
talib and i wrote the book the black
swan
he also wrote uh anti-fragile he since
there's three kinds of people in the
world there's fragile and that's what
our school systems are putting out
fragile 1b snowflakes and that's your
choice you want to be that way
have a good life
the second type is that a fragile like a
champagne flute yeah you hit it it
shatters
then the second one is called robust
and a robust person is like the rock
you know you can pound on them dump on
them yeah
they
take it
but
that's all they do they take it
and that anti-fragile is somebody like
you where they pound the crap out of you
and you get smarter and better because
so i love nazim talent you know a lot of
people call them doctor doom
but
the way i look at this whole thing this
economy is we're probably going after
depression you know we're not going to
get out of this really oh yeah and so
the thing is
is this good for you or bad for you i'm
looking forward to it you know the last
the last crash was 2008
yeah and i made more money in 2008 than
in my whole life
so this one here 2 thousand you know
what are the twenty twenty i'm gonna get
any richer
but they're gonna get poor and if
they're baby boomers they're gonna blame
it on this corona virus oh my you know
that hey hit the road put on some
running shoes change your diet get some
sunlight
you know
get healthy
don't get don't be a wimp
but oh no i'm so afraid of dying i'm
going you're already dead you don't even
know it yet you know
in the marine corps you know in the
marine corps used to call them corpse
people
right
corpse not core yeah of course no a
corpse man a corpse means a person who's
dead but doesn't know it
wow they're so afraid of dying
they're already dead yeah it's about
taking action taking control of your
life taking control your health your
finances everything this is the best
time to be alive right now i don't know
what
people think about money but that's what
i get a lot of is kind of this well you
know money is not spiritual i'm just
saying it's your attitudes you know a
person's attitude towards money i make a
lot of money
but i give a lot you know what i mean
it goes to biblical principle the more
you give the more you receive so when i
meet somebody who's not doesn't have any
money it just means they're not giving
something
yeah you know so a lot of times there's
people who would like more but they're
not giving anything
so they're like my poor dad
and he belong to the labor unions and he
wanted to work less and get paid more
well that's anti-religious to me yeah if
you want to get paid more work more give
more
that's how i see it i'm one of those
kids who doesn't like school
you know school is good
for people who like school
but
here is my poor dad head of education
phd
on the governor's board of hawaii and
all this stuff and his kid me
and i'm flunking out of school because i
can't read i can't write i said i
couldn't read i couldn't write i was
bored out of my mind you know i was just
hey
so what i did instead
was that's when i met my rich dad was my
best friend's father and he used these
things called a game
see games are the best teaching tools
see when i'm playing this game
this is how the rich taught their kids
battle strategies called chess
my rich dad taught me to be a rich man
playing monopoly we played monopoly hour
after hour after hour
you know the formula for great wealth of
monopoly is four greenhouses one red
hotel
so today in arizona i own 8 000 green
hotel i mean greenhouses
and several red hotels
i just play monopoly for real
so that's the power of a game because a
game engages me mentally
physically because i actually have to
move things emotionally because when
somebody knocks me out
i better wake up
you know i made a mistake
and spiritually because it's spirit that
wins now if you just saw golden state
play the
play there
you know everybody's i love lebron james
i love cleveland you know
but
one guy cannot take on a team and i
think lebron scores 60 of all the points
in assists and all that but a better
team beat them
so when you look at
business
business is the same thing
but this is a team sport i have to have
good accountants good attorneys good
marketing guys good tech guys
great staff i have to have great leaders
you know
the trouble with most entrepreneurs are
self-employed
so they quit their job and you know in
america today the sba the small business
administration says there's 28 million
small business owners
28 million
24 million are classified as
non-employers
remember their one-man team
you know the day like this guy said okay
i'm gonna take you on
are you crazy
but that's what most entrepreneurs are
trying to do
because that's what they're taught to do
in school to be the rugged individual
you know in school i was very successful
as long as i could cooperate at test
time
but in school cooperation at test time
is called cheating
in the real world the guys have the
biggest team win
so all i focus on is putting the best
team together
meanwhile a lot of time the a students
in school that the doctors and lawyers
are sitting there all by themselves
they're sitting ducks
but they're entrepreneurs
they're it's just a mindset
tactics strategy i went to military
school i'm a former marine
so i think like a military operation
which i love chess
so most most entrepreneurs you know they
have this job okay i'm gonna be an
entrepreneur and this guy says massacre
that's right because they went to school
they'll learn to get a job and they take
tests on their own
they have to be the smartest
that's like the lebron james
i don't want to be the smartest guy in
my team but i want to have the best team
and that's why i win most of my games
that's great
i think like this and the doctors think
like this and
yeah i got you man
for some reason i get the sense i'm
going to win
i made the my usual wise ass remark only
lazy people use their own money
and that's because
i have spent much of my life raising
capital you know today you have crowd
funding and all that stuff
but the reason i had to learn to raise
money was because i had no money
and so if you read rich dad poor dad
in there my my rich dad always said
never say i can't afford it
and it was my rich dad and many of my
teachers subsequent to that
this lazy people
always say i can't afford it
i don't have the money
that's why they're poor they have a poor
mindset so instead of figuring out how
to raise money it's just really easy to
be a loser and i call it losers if this
is enough
because we all have the power if we
wanted to
to not be poor if we learned how to
raise money what i found out the
accountants and attorneys who went to
the biggest schools are not the best
i have found what i'm looking for
is somebody who may be a private guy who
is passionate about entrepreneurship so
they're a great attorney
for entrepreneurs
you know they're not you know most
attorneys looking for the big client
like i want to work for
you know general electric
what i want is
the attorney and the account who are
passionate about it being entrepreneurs
so my
my guys right here in phoenix are
entrepreneurs
and my accountants are entrepreneurs
every time i hired the big name
corporate and law
accounting firms i have been grossly
overpaid and underserved
because they're so used to doing bigger
things they don't have time for a little
guy like me
it's the same with bankers
i'm looking for a banker who loves being
an entrepreneur you know you got to have
this partnership with the bank you know
i i dump on the financial services
industry a lot and they deserve to be
dumped on
but
you got to have one on your team you
know so my banker is the love of my life
because that's where i get my money from
i don't know if it's good news except to
be careful
um
you know
what changed my life was a book like it
did for many people it was this book it
was called the grunge of giants
and it's by dr r buckminster fuller and
grunt stands for gross universal cash
heist
so when i was i think in my 30s i went
to study with fuller you know he's most
well known for the geodesic dome
and i first saw his geodesic dome
in
montreal canada expo 67 the world's fair
on the future
so my classmate from school in new york
we hitchhiked up to um montreal
just to see bucky's dome it was a u.s
pavilion and it blew me away
you know and
but we all have these events and
teachers in our lives and so i think the
good news is that there's a teacher like
you online now the best teachers are on
youtube not in schools anymore
and um i think that's really the good
news is what we're doing is the news
what's happening in the news today is
fake it's the old news
this um
it's tragic
this corona virus you know like
i don't know it's real i mean the virus
is real
but the media terrorism
is frightening
so i've already been warned many times
to stay in my lane don't go into
medicine
don't go into this virus
stay teaching people with my little cash
flow game
you know i'm talking about stay small or
will stomp on you
so i just remember back in 19 so i i
first went to the dome
in montreal at the world's fair in 67
and i studied with fuller in 1981 and i
started in 81 82 and 83 and he was
predicting the future
he told us what was coming
and as i've said many times many people
it's not what i want to do i don't do
what i love
i ask myself what does god want done
and what god wants done is real
education my opinion and his financial
education and there is no real financial
education in our school systems and
that's not a mistake
so i um that was in 81 and 83.
i couldn't take it anymore i read i read
grunge of giants
and i understood it because my rich dad
kept saying somebody's messing with us
and every time you say that you know
you're a tin hat guy your aluminum hat
you're a conspiracy or a spaceship or an
alien guy and i'm just saying now i'm an
entrepreneur
at the time i was in rock and roll
and my first date with kim was to the
police
you know and and
she was out front having a good time and
i wasn't back with the attorneys
negotiating a contract
so i'm not really a rock and roller but
i'm an entrepreneur
and at that time i said what does god
want done
not what i want to do i love rock and
roll
and what god wants done is financial
education that was my opinion but the
as i was in 83.
so yesterday you know and so i don't
know if i'm if that's what i'm supposed
to do because you'll never know
you'll never know what god once done
if you want to see the top 10 rules
video i did on robert kiyosaki check it
out right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there you don't like to
live below your means do you no no
and i think when you say to somebody
live below your means you wipe the
spirit out look
i have a i have an unfair advantage you
know i went to war